so listen i've got people in my audience  mad at me because i said that some blame  for the roe v wade supreme court  decision goes to the people who didn't  take the risk of trump seriously enough  in 2016. it's okay to say that as long  as it's proportional primarily the blame  for this is the supreme court justices  who voted to overturn roe v wade  trump for appointing them to the supreme  court and the people who voted for  donald trump in 2016. but also there  were people  who  took the risk they thought it was worth  it they said oh trump and hillary are  the same or i'm going to stay home or if  it's not whoever i'm not voting  and this is what we got they're not  primarily to blame but there's plenty of  blame here to go around